a searing summer heat wave bringing
record-breaking temperatures to much of
europe and sparking wildfires across the
continent
in france thousands of people have been
forced to evacuate as wildfires in the
country's southwest
rage out of control
more than 7 thousand hectares have been
destroyed with residents describing the
scene as post-apocalyptic
this evacuation center in gerond serving
as a refuge for residents
we have received almost 500 offers of
accommodation from the inhabitants in
the surrounding area it's an exceptional
movement of solidarity
in spain temperatures have been topping
40 degrees celsius for several days
emergency centers in the capital of
madrid are seeing an increase of coals
we see many people who do not have the
money to keep their houses cool due to
the energy crisis we are having
some don't even have adequate air
conditioning which is a very big issue
at this time of the year there are
houses you enter and you think how can
they stand to be here for even five
minutes
the ongoing drought in portugal and
spain provides ideal conditions for
wildfires to spread
the city of seville has become the first
in the world to take part in a pilot
program to categorize heat waves in an
effort to save lives
climate-driven extreme heat is killing
more people than any other of the
climate-driven hazards and
heat is invisible it is silent
and it kills slowly
and people are not aware of it
and for the first time the uk has issued
a heat red alert warning of a surge in
heat related hospital admissions
record temperatures are putting even
healthy people at risk of serious
illness
and death
the heat wave is expected to continue
well into next week as the climate
crisis becomes more clear and the call
to action
more loud
join wolf al jazeera